die Regale im Supermarkt sind fast leer
es fehlt an allem in Bergkarabach
wie jeden Morgen hofft auch Heiko ganjan
dass er noch was zu essen bekommt er
musste früh aufstehen um rechtzeitig
hier zu sein einen Platz in der Schlange
zu ergattern aber er hat kein Glück
es gibt hier drei Läden aber wie Sie
sehen können sind die geschlossen es
gibt kein Gemüse wir spüren die
Entbehrung sehr stark
seit einigen Tagen werden Lebensmittel
rationiert Essensmarken ausgegeben
120.000 Menschen sind in Bergkarabach
eingeschlossen darunter 30.000 Kinder
völkerrechtlich gehört berkara Bach zu
Aserbaidschan wird aber fast
ausschließlich von Armenien bewohnt
seitdem letzten Krieg vor zweieinhalb
Jahren führt nur der schmale
latschienenkorridor von Armenien nach
Bergkarabach jetzt kommt fast niemand
mehr raus oder rein so wie Haix Frau
ramella sie ist kurz vor der Blockade
nach Armenien gefahren um ihre kranke
Mutter zu versorgen und sitzt nun dort
fest ihren kleinen Sohn sieht sie nur im
Videocall
der Kleine spielt mit der Kamera komm
lass uns ein Foto mit deiner Mutter
machen
seit dem Krieg 2020 kontrolliert
Aserbaidschan auch die Gaszufuhr das
Elektrizitätsnetz immer wieder sitzen
sie hier deshalb bei Kerzenschein für
den zweijährigen Sohn fehlen Windeln und
gesunde Lebensmittel
Aserbaidschan wolle die Armenier in
Bergkarabach aushungern sie so aus der
Region vertreiben glaubt
en kamen früher tausende Lastwagen aus
Armenien mit Lebensmitteln und anderen
Produkten jetzt kommen nur noch ganz
selten Lieferungen vom Roten Kreuz aber
die Regale hier sind leer alles wird
immer knapper
[Musik]
dass seine Frau bald wieder bei Ihnen
sein kann der Konvoi des Roten Kreuzes
ist ihre einzige Chance aber der fährt
nur selten viele Wochen tut sich gar
nichts
seit Dezember blockieren aserbaidschana
den Zugang nach Bergkarabach
Umweltaktivisten behauptet Aserbaidschan
die gegen vermeintliche Verstöße im
Bergbau protestierten eine Darstellung
die Armenien und auch die USA etwa
absurd finden
die Schließung des latschenkorridors ist
eine Provokation das Ziel Aserbaidschan
ist eine neue militärische Eskalation
und wir sollten nicht auf diejenigen
zugehen die so ein eskalationsszenario
entwerfen
die Blockade ist das jüngste Kapitel in
einem Jahrzehnte alten Konflikt immer
wieder gab es Kriege um Bergkarabach den
Zugang über den latschinkorridor sollen
eigentlich russische Truppen
gewährleisten doch Moskau tut bislang
kaum etwas die internationale
Gemeinschaft müsse eine friedliche
Lösung vermitteln fordert deshalb der
Staatsminister von Bergkarabach
wir müssen uns an alle Opfer erinnern
die es schon gab das ist der einzige Weg
der Weg den Aserbaidschan gerade
anbietet nämlich ein berkerer Bach ohne
Armenia das ist eine Sackgasse die
könnte dazu führen dass das
kriegs-pendel in die andere Richtung
ausschlagen wird
in der armenischen Hauptstadt jerevan
treffen wir ramella Haix Frau die hier
fest sitzt sie besorgt Verbandsmaterial
Medikamente für ihre schwerkranke Mutter
hier bekommt sie immerhin alles was sie
braucht in Bergkarabach wäre das
deutlich schwieriger
es gibt diese Ängste wenn wir daran
denken nach Hause zurückzukehren dort
sind die Apotheken leer aber es gibt
immer noch Hoffnung dass wir die
notwendigen Medikamente finden und meine
Mutter sagt die beste Medizin für sie
ist ihr zu Hause und ihre Enkelkinder
also wollen wir nach Hause aber
natürlich wird das Probleme geben
auch Obst Gemüse Dinge die sie hier mal
eben auf dem Weg nach Hause kaufen kann
gibt es in Bergkarabach im Moment kaum
dabei braucht ramellas Mutter dringend
Vitamine und deine beheizte Wohnung sie
hat einen Gehirntumor wurde vor kurzem
operiert trotzdem wollen beide sobald
wie möglich nach Bergkarabach zurück
sich nicht vertreiben lassen
wir wollen dort leben weil mein
Großvater meine Großmutter von dort
stammen sie alle haben in den Kriegen
gekämpft auch mein Vater jetzt mein Mann
mein Bruder sie alle haben für dieses
Land gekämpft wie können wir es
verlassen
zehn Tage nach dem ersten Treffen
erfahren wir das hike endlich Erfolg
hatte jeden Tag hat er mit dem Roten
Kreuz gesprochen damit seine Frau
zurückkommen kann jetzt wartet er mit
seinem Sohn auf sie hofft dass sie es
geschafft hat
dann endlich der Konvoi vom Roten Kreuz
ramella ist dabei
das Wichtigste war bestimmt erst mal
unser Kind so umarmen
ja mein einziger Wunsch gerade ist mein
Kind und meinen Mann zu umarmen mehr
nicht
auch ramellas kranke Mutter war im
Konvoi will sich aber diesmal nicht
filmen lassen
vorübergehend sind sie erleichtert
wenigstens ein paar Familien die wieder
vereint sind doch Aserbaidschan lässt
nicht locker sie sind eingesperrt in
Bergkarabach ihre Zukunft in der Heimat
ungewiss